ANANT SHUKLA: Joining us all
the way from the United Kingdom,
please give a warm
welcome to Polly Samson.
[APPLAUSE]
So, Polly, let's
start off a little bit
about your upbringing and kind
of how your career started.
So tell me about that
journey to becoming a writer.
Where did you decide as
a student or as a child
that writing was what
you were going to pursue?
POLLY SAMSON: I've never decided
to write because I always
wrote.
And it wasn't until I had my
own children, and some of them
write and some of them
not such ready writers,
but when I had my own children
I sort of-- aged about five
and I was thinking, well where
are all these little stories
and poems, you know,
waiting for this eruption
of writing that never happened.
I then realized that it
was just something in me.
And it was something
I'd always done.
And so there wasn't a
sort of blinding flash
where I decided to be a writer.
It was just a
natural progression.
ANANT SHUKLA: Progression, yeah.
There's bits and pieces
of your family history
that shows up in both of the
collections and the novel
as well kind of.
Is there a particular
story that inspired you
for a certain passage or--
you have a rich family history
that just learning
about is fascinating,
I'm sure, for the audience.
POLLY SAMSON: It's a great
well, my family history.
For those who don't
know, my parents
were both refugees
into England in 1938.
My mother was 6 at the
time, half Chinese,
coming from Shanghai
fleeing the Japanese.
And my father, who
was 10 at the time,
came from Hamburg on
the Kindertransport.
I mean obviously they
didn't meet then.
They had very
different journeys.
My father, there was
a large Jewish family
that embraced him.
And he went on to study
and become a journalist.
My mother, unfortunately,
ended up in an orphanage
and at the age of 16 took
herself back to China
to find her father.
She didn't find her father
but she found a revolution.
And she joined Mao's army and
for 10 years was in Red China
until eventually
she got out again.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
POLLY SAMSON: So there's a
lot there for me to draw on.
And I don't directly write
about their histories
but it certainly
informs a lot that I do.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
Along that journey of
writing between novelist,
between short stories,
obviously there's
a different process
that's involved.
Mentally you need to change
the way you're going to write.
Can you tell me a little
bit about that transition
between the different
writing styles,
between lyrics,
between-- if there's
major events kind of
that drive you again
in one of these
directions or this
is when you decided I'm
done with my first novel
and now I'm going to
work on short stories.
Now I'm going to try lyrics.
Kind of how did that begin?
POLLY SAMSON: No,
it's again, I think
every story finds its medium.
Writing a short story
is almost simpler
because you can keep the
whole idea in your head
without feeling like your
brain is going to explode.
It's very containable.
It goes very well with
having small children
actually because you don't
need to write anything down.
But you've got this
whole other secret world.
And you're sort of
wandering around doing
the rest of your life and
kind of writing and editing.
So that by the time I write a
short story, it's like typing.
I've worked on it
so much in my head.
But with a novel,
you know, your brain
would explode if you tried
to keep a whole novel
in your head in that way.
So you have to be more,
in a way more rigorous.
You have to sit at your desk
every day and work on it.
And certainly towards the
end of writing a novel,
there's a sort of
feeling of mounting panic
that you really don't want
to leave your desk at all.
I can remember when I was
writing my first novel
and, you know,
the family kind of
knew to leave me alone in
the later stages of it.
And there was this knock at
the door and it was my husband.
And he said, we need to
go to parents evening.
And I said, why do I have
to go to parents evening?
And he said, you're a parent?
So that gets a
little obsessional.
And then lyric writing
is different again
because I'm not drawing
entirely on something in me.
I've got this
wonderful prompt which
is that the music comes first.
So lyric writing, again,
it takes place mainly
when I'm walking, much
less sitting at the desk.
And I have-- I do
one song at a time.
And I have a track
in my earphones.
And it's playing and playing
and playing and I often do that.
I think it's often referred to
as the Paul McCartney method.
You know, scrambled
eggs was "Yesterday".
And I start to make
up something and then
gradually some sort of
meaning will emerge.
And so it's miles on the
feet for a song as well.
ANANT SHUKLA: So even
within "The Kindness"
I think there are entire
chapters that on their own
could be a short story.
Did you find yourself
picking up pieces
that you didn't include
in "Perfect Lives"
or in other kind
of collections you
were working on that you then
incorporated in and changed
the characters or--
POLLY SAMSON: No, not really.
ANANT SHUKLA: Do
you have a stash
that you keep somewhere
of material I want to--
POLLY SAMSON: I
really wish I did.
I don't, actually.
"The Kindness" started
life in a different format.
I was feeling quite
militant about short stories
because publishers
certainly in the UK,
I think it's different
in the US, but in the UK
there's a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy,
oh you know, short
stories don't sell.
And so my last collection
had been a collection
of linked short stories.
And so I thought, well I'll
take this one stage further.
I'll do a novella.
And at the end of the novella,
my main character, Julian,
would have an explosion
of creativity and within
that he would write
some short stories that
would show that he's come
to some sort of realization
of the events of his life
that he hadn't understood
in the novella.
And so I did start
"The Kindness"
by writing his short stories
and then very quickly realized
that however militant I
felt about short stories,
it was better to
get the novel right
and that it needed
to be a novel.
And things find their form.
And that demanded to be a novel.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
You mentioned about your
creative process walking.
Kind of for you, where do
you find that inspiration?
Is it just walking the dog
outside, taking in the air,
sitting in your study.
You've mentioned a
few different things.
POLLY SAMSON: Yeah, well I can't
sit and stare at a blank screen
because I find that
really agitating.
And I don't know how
anyone does that.
I mean there are a
lot of people who'll
say writing is about
fixing the bum to the seat.
Well I don't really
agree with that.
I think, you know, I've
got a really grateful dog.
He's very keen on
this idea that writing
is about doing about
10 miles walking a day.
And I think that if you walk
and you're thinking about it,
and I often do something
called method writing, where
I walk as my character,
and whatever is happening,
I see it through my
character's eyes.
And you know it can be
quite embarrassing at times,
you know, because my main
character in "The Kindness"
is a man called Julian.
You know, women are coming
towards me and I'm Julian
and I'm giving them the
once over because I really
convince myself that
I am that character.
And by the time you get back
to the desk, it does, it flows.
You know, if you put the
miles in on your feet
and you've really
managed to think about it
and you've really got under
the skin of that character,
there's no trouble once
you get back to your desk.
ANANT SHUKLA: I know we've
talked-- you write some times
about the inspiration.
Are there particular
authors that
have influenced you a
lot, a particular time
period in writing, whether
it's UK literary, history
American literary history, other
parts of the world where you're
drawing short stories and fables
that have been strung together?
For you, who are those
kind of well muses?
POLLY SAMSON: Well my
main inspiration probably
came from-- I
worked in publishing
in the 1980s in the UK.
And I worked for a company
called Jonathan Cape which
was the literary publisher.
And it was run by a total
genius called Tom Maschler.
And, you know, I mean he
invented the Booker Prize,
for example.
He published, you name some
great authors, Martin Amis,
Ian McEwan, Nadine Gordimer,
Doris Lessing, Bruce Chatwin,
Margaret Atwood, Salman Rushdie.
You know, I mean it was
just ridiculous our list.
You know, it was a
wonderful place to work.
And it meant that I read really,
really great books for my job.
It was heavenly.
And so I think that
period of literature
has been very influential
because I read so much of it.
And nowadays I still read
a lot of my contemporaries
but I'm having a surreal
moment of catching up
with the Victorians and
I'm loving it, actually.
It's good to go back.
There is so much great
stuff in every period.
And then poetry-- when
I'm writing fiction
I don't read fiction-- but
I start every day by reading
really good poetry and different
poets for different books.
I mean "Perfect Lives" I read
a lot of Neruda strangely.
And for "The
Kindness", I started
with one of my favorite
poets W.B. Yeats
and then very quickly
realized that I really
needed to get into
John Milton because I'd
made Julian a Milton scholar.
So I spent a year
reading "Paradise Lost"
which was not a year lost to me.
It was a wonderful year.
And then another
poet who I adore
is a contemporary poet
called David Wevill who--
I don't know how well known
he is but he is amazing.
And I'd say that
if anyone's looking
for a contemporary
poet-- he lives in Texas.
I think he's probably
in his 80s by now--
he has published since the
early '60s consistently.
Not a bad word
flows from his pen.
Just incredible stuff.
ANANT SHUKLA: You just
mentioned "Paradise Lost".
I think there are
overt references.
There are references
that you would
have to read the kind
of whole story together.
For you was that the
driving factor in your-- I
know you mentioned you don't
organize it kind of in a web--
but how did you decide where
to weave in "Paradise Lost"?
Or did you have a scheme
or an outline for you
that you said these
are references.
I know Zephyr.
I know there's Lucifer.
He's a scholar.
POLLY SAMSON: Yeah, it just
gave me a feeling of glee
while I was writing because
it's a kind of secret layer
in the book because
actually I think
there are very few people who
really know "Paradise Lost".
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah, here it's
required reading, I think,
in middle school, high
school, and then people forget
about it.
POLLY SAMSON: And I
think in England it's
also required reading.
And I think there's nothing
like required reading
to put people off a writer.
And so I was lucky, you know.
I have no formal education
so I came to it on my own.
And it was a joy
because it takes you off
into so many areas, you know,
labyrinthine kind of footnotes.
If you get the Longman edition
which has amazing notes
I mean the classical references,
the biblical references.
It's an education all
on its own as well as
being the most extraordinary
piece of writing.
And so, yeah, I
think-- I'm sorry.
What was the question?
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah, I think
you've answered it, yeah.
And along with that,
I think the research,
I know you do a lot of research
going into your novels.
For you this novel took a
little bit longer to write.
Kind of why did it
take longer this time?
Was it the research that
you were doing differently?
Are you researching
characters specifically?
Or you come up with an idea
for a plot and then decide,
if I research this,
it'll become a lot
more concrete and descriptive.
POLLY SAMSON: Well I think
I could blame YouTube
for some of the time that
it took because, of course,
it is the perfect
writer's resource.
You don't have to go and
wander around Amsterdam.
You can just go on to YouTube
and you can find that street
and you can find
lovely clips of it.
And it really does
help enormously.
I mean, another
thing that YouTube
was brilliant for while
I was writing this novel
was there's a scene, and
it's quite a pivotal scene,
where my character Julian gets
to see-- he has a friend who's
a medical student--
and he gets to see
his sperm under the microscope.
And I wanted to
write this piece.
write it, you know,
I didn't want to just write,
and they look like tadpoles.
I wanted to kind
of get something
more out of the scene because
it's such an important scene.
And so I thought,
oh I'm going to have
to go to a fertility clinic
or what am I going to do.
And then eventually
I went YouTube.
They'll be a scientist.
He'll have posted some
sperm under the microscope.
So it was like a little
bit of trepidation
to put it in the search.
And what came up was very
surprising and very helpful,
which is that a lot
of young men seem
to like to make films of their
sperm under the microscope
and post them onto YouTube and
play a guitar solo with them.
So hurray for those men.
So yeah, I got to write that
passage with plenty of input
from YouTube and it was great.
ANANT SHUKLA:
Timing wise, right,
I think you had other
events going on in your life
that you worked on it for a
bit, put it aside, came back.
POLLY SAMSON: I
think the reason it
took-- my first
novel to first draft
took six weeks and this one to
first draft took over a year.
And I think really
the main difference
was that with my first novel
I had a lot of small children.
So it was like I've
got to get it done.
I've got to get it done.
You know, I'm really meant to
be doing something else here.
Got to get this done.
And I was able to take my
time with my second novel.
And you know it's a luxury.
It's a luxury to take your time.
That's good.
ANANT SHUKLA:
Shifting gears a bit,
we've talked a lot
about "The Kindness".
For the "Perfect Lives" kind
of I found it very fascinating
the way you've
structured the story.
It is not necessarily
a linear kind
of plot line, the
characters again
weaving in and out of
each other's lives.
For you, kind of, where did that
idea and inspiration come from?
POLLY SAMSON: It
was never planned.
And nothing I ever write
seems to be planned.
Everything takes on
a life of its own.
And with "Perfect
Lives" it really
was that I wrote one story,
and then I wrote another story.
And what happened, for
example, the reason
that the characters
kept emerging was they
kept kind of-- a character who
was a minor character in one
story, I'd come to
write the next story
and this character would
be sticking the hand up.
Me, me, me.
Write about me.
And so for example
the first story
I wrote was called
Barcarolle and it
was about a piano tuner
who has terrible--
He was supposed to
be a concert pianist
and then stage
fright did for him.
And it's during
his day as a piano
tuner he meets a lot of
pianos and a lot of people.
So I'd written that story.
And then I knew that the
next story I wanted to write
was inspired by my
husband's last tour,
the On an Island tour.
We went to Hamburg
which is where
my Jewish family were from.
And I was standing at
the back of the stage
while the audience were sort
of screaming for an encore.
And I had a really unhealthy
conflicted feeling.
I had to keep saying,
it's not them.
It's not them.
There was something about
these people shouting
that gave me the chills.
And I wanted to express that
second-hand memory thing.
You know nothing
happened to me but it
happened to my ancestors.
And they didn't do anything
but maybe their ancestors did.
And it's a very
difficult emotion.
And so I wanted to explore that.
And so I knew that I was
going to have a musician.
And I knew she was
going to be Jewish.
going to go to Hamburg
and she was going to play.
And she was going to
have those feelings.
And so I was thinking, well
maybe I'll make her a pianist.
Yeah, OK, who is she?
And then I sort of thought back
to the story I had just written
and there was just a minor
character in their called,
whose piano was being tuned,
called Aurelia Leiberman.
And I thought Leiberman?
She's obviously Jewish.
And so that's really how
one emerges from another.
It's really not planned
and then it gets to be fun.
You know, once you're
a few stories in,
you do, you start looking
for them and thinking,
I'm going to tell your a story.
And it's great.
It's really, really a
lovely form, I think,
the linked short story form.
I'm a huge fan of linked
short stories anyway.
I mean I love Elizabeth Strout's
"Olive Kitteridge" and I love,
there's a book by Daniel
Kehlmann called "Fame" which
is again linked stories.
Wonderful, I think.
It's a good form.
ANANT SHUKLA: You touched upon
the piano and piano tuner.
The piano seems to manifest
itself in almost every story.
Kind of for you, what
is that symbolism?
Is it from your own
musical background
that you want to use that
as the main motif or--
POLLY SAMSON: Yes, well what
happened was I had three sons
and I wrote.
And then I had a
princess and I also
knew she's going
to be my last baby.
So I told myself I
wasn't going to write
because of having this
rather obsessive personality.
Writing kind of blots out
children while I'm doing it.
And I thought, I'm really
going to just enjoy my children
and particularly my last child.
I'm not going to write.
And a couple of my boys
were learning piano.
And when they had to do
their piano practice,
you know like lots
of boys, there
didn't seem to be
anything you could
do to persuade them to sit
down and do their practice.
And so I said to
the piano teacher,
would it help if
I learned and then
at least I could be helpful.
And she said yeah, that
sounds like a good idea.
But the thing is
I am quite a geek.
So as soon as I
started learning,
I kind of took it all in like
I was spending sort of hours.
I could have been writing.
Learning the piano,
I mean, I was playing
the piano for five hours a day.
The children would
come home and they'd
say I need to do
my piano practice.
Sorry, I'm doing mine right now.
Took all the exams.
I was like a child prodigy.
Rose up through the levels
and kept on taking the exams,
kept on playing the piano.
But it's not my thing.
And so when it
came to the moment
when my daughter then
went to nursery school
and I knew that it was time
to start writing again,
I was just absolutely
soaked in piano.
And you know the piano became
the metaphor for everything
I wanted to say.
There's so much to do with
learning a musical instrument
that's fascinating.
ANANT SHUKLA: So I think
this is a good segue
for our next section.
We just talked about
your musical piano
training and whatnot.
So let's listen
to a bit of a clip
from some of the lyrics
you've worked on.
And we can discuss with you
your songwriting process.
[MUSIC - PINK FLOYD, "HIGH
HOPES]
ANANT SHUKLA: So how did this
collaboration with your husband
begin?
POLLY SAMSON: He wasn't
my husband at the time.
He was my boyfriend.
He had gone into a
studio and he was
jamming with Rick Wright and
Nick Mason for the first time,
I think, since the '70s that
they played freely together.
I at the time had what's in
England called glandular fever.
Here I think it's
called Epstein-Barr.
So I was at home with a
massively high temperature.
And he'd come back
in the evenings
and play me this beautiful
music and then say,
but yeah, I just need a lyric.
I was working as a journalist
at the Sunday Times right then.
I had no desire
to be a lyricist.
But I was lying
there with this fever
and I would occasionally sort
of say some obscure thing,
kind of, I was just thinking
about ivy growing over a door,
and he would write it down.
And then these things would
start sort of emerging.
And so it kind of,
he'd show me something
and he'd say I think
this would work.
And I'd look at it once
I'd taken something
to bring the fever down.
And I'd think, not sure
that does work quite.
Let me have a little
fiddle with that.
And so it progressed and then
it became more formalized.
And at the beginning
he said that, you know,
that he agreed that I wouldn't
have to have my name on it.
And I know that sounds odd.
But it was a different
world back then.
It was a misogynist culture,
particularly rock and roll.
Pink Floyd I don't think had
had any female contributors.
I had this real sort of terror
that if my name was on it,
I would-- somehow people would
start calling me Yoko Ono.
And I think about
that now and I think
what would be wrong with that?
I mean she's an amazing artist.
She's an innovator.
She's never stopped.
She's incredible.
She's a woman in her 80s
who's still producing new art.
So I now think,
please, you know,
if anyone would like to call
me Yoko Ono I'll accept that
with grace and
enormous happiness.
But at the time that seemed
like kind of an insult.
And so David said, OK
it's fine, I'll pay you,
and I thought, yeah, but your
name doesn't need to be on it.
And then by the
time we'd finished,
he sort of said, I'm
sorry but, you know,
you're getting a credit.
Your name's going on it.
And one day you will
thank me because you
know uncredited work
is a horrible feeling.
And he was right because I'm
really proud of that work.
And of course now I
would really hate it
if my name wasn't on it.
But at the time I was
a shrinking violet.
ANANT SHUKLA: Again
here, I know David often
mentions you're his muse.
For you, again,
when you're writing,
is there a muse that's
spurring on a certain lyric one
way or the other
or again is it just
you're walking
outside with a tune,
you writing and composing?
POLLY SAMSON: Well
it's the tune.
I mean the muse is the
tune and so I suppose
the tune has come from David.
So you know, I mean, I know
it sounds a bit happy couple-y
but I'd have to say that
the muse for the lyrics
is quite clearly David because
the music is always first.
And it's a wonderful
thing to write a lyric
because you have this prompt.
You know, instead of that
thing, there's no blank page
because it's there.
The music is there.
When I write a lyric, he
scats a top line melody.
And the scat, it feels like
it's just under the surface
there are these
words and it's just
a matter of sort of bringing
them up to the surface.
It's a very different process
from writing something
from what I think of as scratch.
ANANT SHUKLA: Is there ever an
instance where the lyrics came
first and then the music or?
POLLY SAMSON: I think
just once and that
was on the last Pink Floyd
album, "The Endless River".
And because it was--
the "Endless River"
was put together from that
session I mentioned earlier.
There were so many
beautiful pieces of music
and about 10 or 11 of them made
it on to the "Division Bell".
And for years we'd always been
listening to the other bits
of music, you know.
And they were lovely and
so there came a moment
where it just felt that
those pieces of music
should be released.
And Rick had sadly died.
And so I just felt awkward about
imposing a lyric on something
from a time when Rick was alive.
And so I didn't want to
write it to a piece of music
but I knew that
David wanted a song.
And I knew that he wanted a
song to be that big full stop
on the Pink Floyd history.
So I wrote that song to "Louder
Than Words" to sort of try
and sum up the thing to
do that I'd noticed most
about the members of Pink
Floyd which is just how
eloquently they speak to each
other with musical instruments.
But put them in a room
together and it is the most
awkward thing you can imagine.
No one speaks.
It's so yeah, so that's
what that song's about.
It's about men who don't use
words to speak to each other
but who have something else.
ANANT SHUKLA: Awesome.
Yeah, I think we're
going to listen
to another clip from the solo
album "Rattle That Lock".
This one is called
"In Any Tongue".
Let's get the AV back up.
[MUSIC - DAVID GILMOUR, "IN ANY
TONGUE"]
ANANT SHUKLA: So obviously
some very strong war motifs,
the video itself as well.
Tell me a little bit about
the process behind this song
and if it was any different
from what you just mentioned.
POLLY SAMSON: Well
this was in a way
quite a daunting song to write.
And it was the last
one that I wrote
for the "Rattle That Lock".
And it was a piece of music
that was so suggestive of what
it had to be about.
And I for some reason felt
inhibited by the enormity
of that subject, you
know, the wastage of war.
And so I spent a long time
reading poetry, basically
the poetry of
conscience, so you know
poetry written by people who
had served in Afghanistan,
a lot of different poetry.
I mean I even read the
poetry of the Taliban.
I wanted to sort of read a
lot of poetry to do with war.
And I kind of got really
bogged down in it, I mean.
And it got to the point where
I couldn't write a word.
And so I read more and more of
these collections of poetry.
And in the end David
said, it doesn't matter,
it doesn't matter.
You know, if it doesn't
make it on to the album,
it doesn't matter.
You know he's very,
very good like that.
And I think it was
kind of the last day.
And I thought, oh it's
such a great tune.
I don't want to be
responsible for this not going
on the album.
And I sat in the
sunshine and just
thought, why am I making
such a meal of this.
I know what I think.
I know exactly what I think.
And I think I wrote the lyric
in maybe 10 minutes once I'd
give myself a firm talking to.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
I think we want to open
it up to any audience
Q&A. If you guys
have any questions,
now's a great time to
ask Polly on everything
she's talked about.
We have some mics that
will be coming around.
AUDIENCE: Polly, when
you write a short story
you said you have-- you sort
of have it floating your head.
When you're doing a novel,
are you carrying the ending
in your head and then you're
just letting the story progress
and the characters develop?
You don't really know how you're
going to get to the ending?
POLLY SAMSON: Yeah.
It's a great question
because it is very different
from a short story,
writing a novel.
And I think it's very
different for different sorts
of novelists.
I have a friend who
plots the whole thing.
And I'm quite envious, really.
You go look in her
writing room and there it
is, chapter 1, chapter 2.
And she knows
everything she's doing
and it's this
wonderful scaffolding
and she just hangs the
writing on the scaffolding.
But I have to admit
that that would bore me.
I know who my characters are.
I know what their
moral problems are.
I know the moral choices
they have to make.
But other than that, I don't
really know the ending.
And things change.
I mean this method writing,
that's when things change.
I mean walking as that person
and thinking as that person
and responding to things
as that person makes
the story and the journey
to the end very different
from something I
might have thought
I was doing in the beginning.
And that's what makes
it exciting actually
for me is I like the surprises.
I like the way that
things I thought
I was going to do just change.
It's endlessly surprising
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
Question in the back.
AUDIENCE: So
songwriting is something
that's always interested me.
And one of the things
that I've always wondered
is after a certain point,
you become famous, right,
and you're living a different
sort of life than other people
and you're seeing
things that are
different than other people,
than an average person.
And yet often when artists
become famous their albums,
not always, will become better
and better and better, OK,
sometimes worse, but better
and better and better.
And I have always wondered
how do you actually
continue to kind of be
hungry, continue to see things
from the view of
non-famous people
who have a very different,
potentially, view of the world
that maybe you
don't have anymore
and still connect with people.
It's something I've
just always wondered.
How does Pink Floyd
or David or you
get down and still write a song
today that can connect with us?
Thank you.
POLLY SAMSON: Thank you.
I don't feel like I
have a wall anywhere
built between me and anyone.
I don't feel famous,
I mean, and I'm not.
So I can't answer how
it is to be famous.
But I do know that we
live a very ordinary life.
We don't-- we live
an ordinary life.
Our children go to school.
We cook.
We walk.
We walk our dog.
Our friends are
not famous people.
Our friends are, you know--
I feel very connected.
I don't feel my life has changed
because my husband is famous.
If that answers the question.
AUDIENCE: Sort of, I mean in the
sense that it's not just fame,
but it's you first are writing,
when your first writing
songs, your financial
position or view of the world
and everything has got to
be very different than once
you have, whether it's
specifically you that's famous
or that world that
your living in is
a very, very different world.
And I mean, I don't know,
like "Comfortably Numb"
was written about being
on tour or something
like that and
something like this.
That's something that most of
us don't-- it's a great song--
but something most
of us don't have.
I guess it's kind of how
do you think you can still
connect to people.
POLLY SAMSON: OK there is
a one word answer to that.
And it's the most
important thing
that a writer needs to
possess and it's empathy.
So you know it's
what I talked about.
It's about, it's like
method writing, you know.
It is about being able to
get under anyone's skin.
And you know I
don't think there's
a writer alive who
hasn't got empathy
as their greatest skill.
I mean and if they haven't
they shouldn't be writing.
ANANT SHUKLA: Another
question here.
AUDIENCE: So I'll preface this.
I'm not a published
author but I really
understand your method writing
that you were discussing,
that that's kind of
exactly how I do stuff.
But when I do that, I find that
for every one finished product
that's like good and goes
somewhere, that's clever
and other people
might want to read it,
there's probably at least five
to nine other things I like,
eh, it kind of petered out.
It didn't work.
So you have two
published novels and I
was wondering how
many did you start
writing that just didn't
go anywhere or are you able
to salvage them somehow?
ANANT SHUKLA: You've got to
silence your inner critic
because you know you say there
are eight or nine that are not
working.
But that's your inner
critic is telling you that.
And maybe your inner critic
is being too harsh with you.
Just a thought.
I don't have a load of
stuff that I've started.
I tend to kind of-- if I
start something, I finish it.
But I take a long time
to start something.
I have to know that
it's going to take time,
it's going to take energy, and
it's going to be obsessional.
So I have to know that I'm
jumping into the right pool
before I take the leap.
I've written one novel that
didn't reach full gestational
and it got to
about 20,000 words.
And my inner critic
was deafening.
And actually I found it on
an old drive the other day.
And my inner critic on
that occasion was correct.
It was terrible.
But you know I think it's
about starting the right thing
if that's any help.
ANANT SHUKLA: That
kind of segues
to my next question in terms
of what's next for you?
Another novel?
Another short story collection?
POLLY SAMSON: What's next
for me is another novel.
I've got three novels
kind of float--
this is the thing about
selecting the right thing.
There are three ideas kind
of flying around out there
and it's which one to land.
I have no idea at the moment.
And I can't wait to just pick
on one because then again you
can get into that total
obsession, tunnel vision,
and think about nothing but
that research, nothing but that.
And that is the greatest state.
And I also want to
write some more lyrics.
But I can't do both
things at once.
I need to have just one
thing in my head at a time.
So I'm at this
moment, I'm not sure
if it's lyrics
next or novel next.
We'll see.
ANANT SHUKLA: And
outside of writing
I know photography
is a big passion.
What else kind of drives you?
POLLY SAMSON: Well
photography is a big passion
because I'm not a
natural photographer.
I'd say that because
I've always written
and it is the thing--
for most of my life
it has defined me, writing.
And photography doesn't
come naturally to me.
So I love something that
I have to really work at.
And I love learning.
And the piano is the same thing.
I like things that
are incremental.
So you know I've had all sorts
of things that I can juggle.
And that again is a kind of
incremental learning thing.
And yeah, I still play the
piano and I play guitar.
So, yeah, but my
passion is writing.
ANANT SHUKLA: Great, great.
Are there any other
audience questions?
So we're going to
start off with Polly
reading a little bit, one short
passage from "The Kindness".
POLLY SAMSON: So I'm going to
simply read the first three
pages just set in
August 1989 this bit
although the novel
spans 23 years.
"Lucifer flew well for
her in the fading light,
falling through the sky when
she summoned him and away again
towards a great bruising sunset.
She was alone on
the ridge at first,
just her, the bird,
and the wide open view.
It was one of those nervy summer
days of sudden strong winds
that fretted the hawks
feathers as he stared at her
from his perch on her gauntlet.
She was wearing a long red
shirt over jeans and sandals.
Her hair was breaking
free of its band.
A leather pouch hung from
her belt and a whistle
from a cord around her neck.
The hawk braced his feet on her
wrist, making a leather tassel
swing from the gauntlet.
She felt the breath of
his feathers on her face
as he departed.
And she watched him go with
the wind right under his wings,
scattering crows like drops
shaken from an umbrella.
Julia was trying her best to
get it right for the bird.
The morsels were small
to keep him active.
A shaming 26 ounces he'd weighed
on the scales that morning.
She called him with a
whistle, two short bursts.
And there he was.
A dark cupid's bow
firing straight at her
from the heavens.
She continued along
the ridge, Lucifer
steady on her arm, his manic
eyes never leaving her face
until she gave the signal.
She sent him reeling to
and fro and neither of them
knew that this was to
be their last dance.
The evening started to chill.
She'd almost forgotten
that Julian was supposed
to be meeting her there.
Or perhaps she'd
just given up hope.
He was panting when
he arrived, still
red in the face from the
run up the hill, his bike
and its useless tire abandoned.
He had the air of
a boy who'd crossed
three continents to
see her, his sweatshirt
knotted around his waist.
Impossibly young
with hair falling
over his eyes and an uncertain
lope, one leg of his jeans
still tucked into his sock.
He didn't dare
kiss her, he said,
with the hawk glaring
at him like that
from the end of her wrist.
The hawk shrugged his shoulders
and she sent him flying.
They kissed and when Julian
stopped to glance nervously
at the sky, she took
off her gauntlet
and pushed his hand inside.
She urged the hawk
with her whistle,
moving Julian's arm up and down,
the gauntlets tassel dancing.
But Lucifer only
soared higher, the wind
whispering murder into his ear
and deafening him to her call.
Julia ran cursing, Julian
lolloping beside her.
She grabbed back the gauntlet.
And as the hawk
fell to his kill,
Julian's hands were
warm on her waist
and it seemed to them both
that the scream of the rabbit
went on forever.
It was almost midnight when
she got back to Witchwood.
She'd have stayed
at Julian's digs
until morning if it hadn't
been for Lucifer, bloody bird.
She parked the car in the
lane, coaxed him from is crate,
and clipped him on.
Lucifer shook out his
feathers a little irked
that somebody had
carelessly creased his cape.
Fallen twigs cracked
under foot as she
cut through the copse, the
bird a resentful weight
on her arm, the accusatory
glitter of his eyes
the only brightness
beneath the trees.
The darkness dropped.
The branches stilled.
Witchwood stood
alone in the clearing
as unexpected as a
Grimms' Brothers cottage
with its wonky black
boards and crooked windows.
At once she could
see a light was
on though she was certain
she'd switched everything off.
Her face owlish white, Julia
slipped through the back gate,
whispering to Lucifer
as she transferred him
to his post in the shed
and all alone up the path.
Heart beating, a skittering
stone loose at the steps,
she pushed the door
open with her foot
and straight into the kitchen.
A gasp, mostly relief.
Chris, her husband,
streaky hair flat his head,
his giant gray trainers kicked
halfway across the floor,
chinkering his spoon in a cup.
She took half a pace back.
'Why the look of
surprise', he said.
'I live here too, you know'
Maggie, his lurcher, quivered
in disgust beside him,
her nose pressed to his knee.
'So here I am, home.' He
made a mockery of the word,
bristling with it, pointing
his spoon at her like a weapon.
'I wasn't expecting you.'
She hung the leather gauntlet
on its hook, brain racing
for an alibi and stalling.
'You gave me a fright.
You could have been anybody.'
He cursed her for the
welcome, baring teeth older
than his mouth,
Nescafe and tobacco.
'What did you do?
Did you leave Lucifer
in the boot while
'you--' 'I couldn't get the
car to start.' He snatched
the leather pouch from her and
threw the leftover bits of meat
to his dog, then
pulled it inside out.
'If you don't clean it out,
they'll be maggots again.'
He was supposed to be away
until Christmas by which time
Julia promised
herself to be gone.
His overalls fell open to
a Ramones t-shirt so faded
you'd have to already
know the name of the band
and down to a belt with
a large metal buckle.
He unloaded his pockets
over the kitchen counter
tobacco, Murray mints,
rolling papers, dope tin,
change clattering.
His hair was dotted
with gray paint
like flies have been
laying eggs in it.
'It's great you're so
pleased to see me', he said,
'a real treat.' 'Likewise'.
I'll leave it there.
[APPLAUSE]
ANANT SHUKLA: All right.
I think we'll segue then
to the second reading
from "Perfect Lives".
Everybody join me in giving
a great round of applause
for Ms. Polly Samson.
[APPLAUSE]
POLLY SAMSON: Thank you.
So the thing to
say about this is
I've sort of taken a few
little bits of one story
and talking about real
life influencing something
you might write, when I wrote
this story or just before I
wrote it, I had
three friends, three
wonderful, wonderful women who
were married to really, really
boring men.
And these really boring men
left these wonderful women
for other women.
And these women who seemed to
have tired of these boring men,
all became stalkers
of their ex-husbands.
And they would all
tell me about it.
And the material was
just too good to waste.
And you know the internet makes
stalkers of all of us, so yeah.
Anyway it's called "Morgana".
"Morgana burst into my
life, jingling and jangling
armfuls of bracelets and
puffing thin cigarettes
that she rolled herself.
Silk flowers scattered here and
there in twists of dark hair,
fresh from her crisis and
still prone to sudden tears.
My shoulders were not the
kind that usually got cried
on, a bit on the tense side I
suppose what with Simon working
all the time and Angus and
Ivan like leaky pockets,
never full no matter how
much I poured into them.
Morgana's fandango,
what a nightmare.
Things being thrown,
hot cups of tea
across the kitchen, Mike's
clothes into marine parade,
the photographs of their
wedding day removed
from the top of the piano,
put back again twice,
and removed again
with such force
that the glass
shattered in the frames.
She was wild when he left.
A river of tears washing over
a fortnight's dismal blowjobs
that failed to make him stay.
She put half a brick through
the window of the basement
he was renting one night when
he wouldn't open the door.
His girlfriend Elizabeth,
who he pretended
didn't live there
with him at all,
looked up from playing her
oboe straight at Morgana
outside on the pavement, and
laying the oboe carefully
down raised her arms to
release a long skein of hair
from its band,
sending it falling
and swinging down her
back like molten metal
and sashayed to the
telephone to call the police.
Morgana's driving
is not improved
when she tells me
about these things.
I had, though not
without misgiving,
agreed to put my life
in Morgana's hands
a couple of afternoons a week.
She was quite bold
when she suggested it.
Mike did all the driving,
she told me one afternoon
when I'd come with my
films to the studio she ran
from the basement of her house.
'After 29 years in
the passenger seat,
I'll be needing to brush up.
I never even got to touch
the radio in our car.
And the steering wheel was most
definitely out of bounds', she
said, the first time she sat
clutching my car's wheel.
'I'm sure I could drive.
I've definitely got a license
and I can remember taking a red
Mini Moke right up the
middle of Portabella Market.'
I was in awe of her then.
I was nervous when
she developed my films
and printed my
pictures, worrying
that my composition was not good
or the exposures ill judged.
She made prints from
the best of them.
There was glamor to her.
She was festooned
with it, all those
bracelets she wore, the layers
of fine fabrics, the charms
and old meaningful rings that
hung from her neck clustered
together on a long gold chain.
The hints of a rackety
life once lived up and down
the Kings Road.
I called for her on
Tuesdays and Thursdays
at 2:30 in the afternoon
so we had a clear hour
to mow down pedestrians
before I had
to collect my pair of leaky
buckets from their school.
Sometimes I could feel
my poor Peugeot quake.
A variety of stimuli
could set Morgana off.
An alabaster statuette
spied through his window
flaunting its nakedness
atop his new desk.
'Do you suppose it reminds him
of her?' CDs or books spotted
lying on the
backseat of his car,
a thick one with an
irritating title.
'The man on the cover looked
to be in fear of his life,' she
said, rattling my keys at
the ignition irritably.
'What's he doing reading
self-help books?'
Sometimes, Morgana told me,
she couldn't sleep at night
and in the darkness she
tiptoed quite undetected
through the perfumed gardens
of Elizabeth's Facebook.
Elizabeth seemed to have
accepted Morgana's alter ego
as a friend.
I said it just proved
how few friends
she had in the real world.
Bang outside Mike's flat and
into a space either directly
behind or directly
in front of his car
always seemed to Morgana
to be the perfect place
to practice parking
because curtains
were drawn at the front.
They had been since
the last time he'd
allowed her over the threshold.
And much to
Elizabeth's displeasure
and Morgana's later
mortification,
she and Mike had
ended up wrestling
on the floor like bad children.
Once parked, Morgana was
able to nip out and search
for those little sharp
nuggets of information
that she so craved,
peering through the windows
of his black Audi.
I watched her with her
hands against the glass
of the car that had
once been her chariot
and cringed as I imagined
Elizabeth or Mike seeing
her there.
'Awaken the Giant Within'.
'What's that supposed to mean?
When did he ever read books like
that?' She huffed as we pulled
away in a series
of ostrich jerks.
'Mirrors, mirrors' I yelled.
'Silly little girl must be
telling him what to read.
Self help.' Her bracelets
jangled as she thumped
the steering wheel for emphasis.
'He never had any trouble
helping himself', ignoring
the hooting from the car behind.
'What do you suppose I
did to his giant, anyway,
to put it to sleep.' She
scraped the gears as she changed
into third.
'Sorry,' she said to me and to
the man who'd overtaken shaking
his head.
'And he's listening
to Ting Tings.
What's he doing listening to
the Ting Tings?' Thank you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Thanks
again, everybody.